their late last night the Senate did
unanimously approve an historic two
trillion dollar relief bill meant to
ease the economic pain of the
coronavirus it offers hundreds of
billions of dollars to big companies and
small businesses along with cash
payments to many Americans Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy what's next
well next this goes to the House and
senators tell us that once it passes
there some of this money could be put to
work right away especially those loans
to small businesses that convert to
grants banks that are already set up to
do this
we're told could turn that money around
within 36 hours unemployment insurance
for the likely millions of people who
are being laid off should go up by six
hundred dollars a week by next week and
those cash payments you mentioned
Anthony twelve hundred dollars for a lot
of individuals more for families that
money could be directly deposited into
your account within the next three weeks
or so now if the IRS doesn't have your
account information on file it could
take longer up to four months for them
to mail you a paper check now leaders
are hoping that the bills overwhelming
victory in the Senate overnight a ninety
six to zero vote will pave the way for
smooth passage in the house tomorrow
leaders there are hoping to pass the
bill using something called a voice vote
which would enable most members of the
House to stay home to not travel to
Washington they would need unanimous
agreement to let that happen
right now they have their fingers
crossed Gail yeah fingers toes eyes
everything across thank you very much
Nancy